[MUSIC PLAYING]
What I want to do in this video
is talk a little bit
about compounding interest. And
then, have a little bit of
a discussion of a way to
quickly, kind of an
approximate way to
figure out how
quickly something compounds.
And then we'll actually see how
good of an approximation
this really is.
So just as a review, let's say
I'm running some type of a
bank and I tell you that I am
offering 10% interest that
compounds annually.
That's usually not the
case in a real bank.
You would probably compound
continuously.
But I'm just going to
keep it a simple
example, compounding annually.
There are other videos on
compounding continuously.
This makes the math
a little simpler.
And all that means is that,
let's say today you deposit
$100 in that bank account.
If we wait one year and you
just keep that in the bank
account, then you'll have
your $100 plus 10%
on your $100 deposit.
10% of 100 is going
to be another $10.
So after a year, you're
going to have $110.
You can just say I added
10% to the 100.
And after two years, or a year
after that first year, after
two years, you're going to get
10% not just on the $100.
You're going to get
10% on the $110.
So you get 10% on $110.
You're going to get
another $11.
So 10% of $110 is $11.
So you're going to get $110--
that was, you can imagine,
your deposit entering
your second year.
And then you get plus
10% on that.
Not 10% on your initial
deposit.
That's why we say
it compounds.
You get interest on the interest
from previous years.
So $110 plus now $11.
So every year, the amount of
interest we're getting-- if we
don't withdraw anything--
goes up.
So now we have $121.
And I could just keep
doing that.
And the general way to figure
out how much you have after
let's say, n years, is
you multiply it.
I'll use a little bit
of algebra here.
So let's say this
is my original
deposit, or my principal.
However you want to view it.
After x years, so after 1 year,
you would just multiply
it to get-- to this number
right here, you
multiply it by 1.1.
Actually, let me
do it this way.
I don't want to be
too abstract.
So just to get the math here, so
to get to this number right
here, we just multiplied.
That number right there is
100 times 1 plus 10%.
Or you could say 1.1.
Now this number right here
is going to be this
110 times 1.1 again.
So it's this.
It's the 100 times 1.1, which
was this number right there.
And now we're going to multiply
that times 1.1 again.
And remember, where does
the 1.1 come from?
1.1 is the same thing as
100% plus another 10%.
Right?
That's what we're getting.
We have 100% of our original
deposit plus another 10%.
So we're multiplying by 1.1.
Here we're doing that twice.
We multiply by 1.1 twice.
So after three years, how
much money do we have?
So after three years, we're
going to have 100 times 1.1 to
the third power.
After n years-- now we're
getting a little abstract
here-- we're going to have 100
times 1.1 to the nth power.
And now you could imagine, this
is not easy to calculate.
This was all the situation where
we're dealing with 10%.
If we're dealing in a world
where let's say it's 7%.
So let's say this is a different
reality here, where
we have 7% compounding annual
interest. Then after 1 year,
we would have 100 times--
instead of 1.1, it'd be 100%
plus 7% or 1.07.
Let's go to three years.
After three years, I could
do two in between.
It'd be 100 times 1.07
to the third power.
Or 1.07 times itself
three times.
After n years, it'd be 1.07
to the nth power.
So I think you get the sense
here that, although the idea
is reasonably simple, to
actually calculate compounding
interest is actually
pretty difficult.
And even more, let's say I were
to ask you, how long does
it take to double your money?
So if you were to just use this
math right here, you'd
have to say gee, to double my
money, I would have to start
with $100 and I'm going to
multiply that times-- let's
say, whatever.
Let's say it's a 10% interest.
1.1 or 1.10-- depending on how
you want to view it-- to the x
is equal to-- well I'm going
to double my money
so it's going to
have to equal to $200.
And now I'm going to have to
solve for x and I'm going to
have to do some logarithms
here.
You can divide both
sides by 100.
You get 1.1 to the
x is equal to 2.
I just divided both
sides by 100.
And then you could take the
logarithm of both sides base
1.1, and you get x.
And I'm showing you that this
is complicated on purpose.
And if any of this is confusing,
there's multiple
videos on how to solve these.
You get x is equal to
log base 1.1 of 2.
And most of us cannot do
this in our heads.
So although the idea is simple,
how long will it take
for me to double my money?
To actually solve it, to get
the exact answer, is not an
easy thing to do.
If you have a simple calculator,
you can kind of
keep incrementing the number
of years until you get a
number that's close.
But no straightforward
way to do it.
And this is with 10%.
If we're doing it with
9.3% it just
becomes even more difficult.
So what I'm going to do in the
next video is I'm going to
explain something called the
rule of 72, which is an
approximate way to figure
out how long
to answer this question.
How long does it take to double
your-- I forgot the
word, the most important word.
How long does it take to
double your money?
And we'll see how good of an
approximation it is in that
next video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]